- [Siti] Food insecurity
is a real problem in different families.
This is something that I had
to go through growing up,
and so I didn't want anyone
to ever have to spend a night
hungry and not have food.
(lively music)
- [Narrator] This Great Big
Story is by Singapore Airlines.
(lively music)
- My name is Siti Noor Mastura,
and I am the founder of Back2Basics.
Back2Basics is a nonprofit
organization, and what we do
is that monthly we serve
families with groceries.
Food insecurity was an
issue for our family.
Food became a struggle.
Hunger is something so awful,
and you don't think about it
until you're in that situation.
You don't think you will
end up in that situation.
So in 2013, so I actually
started volunteering
with different organizations
with my best friend,
and so that's when I
started talking to her
and saying, "You know what,
we should do something
"about the food
insecurities in Singapore."
(upbeat music)
So the first groceries that we bought
were basically with our own money,
and we delivered it to three houses,
and then it just grew into more families,
and that's what we did
for the next six years.
The next drive that's
happening, it's 31 families.
We have those who are elderly.
We have big families.
We have single parents.
So it's rice, oil, broccoli, onions,
carrots, potatoes, bananas.
Our idea is that
if you're not spending money
buying these basic things,
that money can be rolled out
into something else that you need.
I don't think that poverty
will end in my lifetime,
but I think the point is in knowing
that it's not about
solving everyone's issue.
It's really about making a difference,
even in just one person's life.
And in order to just solve
one person's problem,
it really just takes one person,
and that person can be you.